bene tutti ragazzi e bebè devi stare
fermo e benvenuti a questo nuovo video
io sono fa vj coach e pietro che mi
butta giù e c'è step che fa cose non
family friends devi stare fermo
devi stare a vi sono presa mi sono
attaccato il malato ma si può partire
tranquilli siamo proprio gara che va a
braccetto una mazza va bene allora
ragazzi questo è pesaro a mappa di human
forse sono diverse andremo a fare nei
prossimi video così accordo di
appoggiare la palla di poggiare quindi
entrare tu con la palla non funziona ma
già per terra che la colpì e va bene
allora fai tu eri balia dei venti che
non dovevi entrare il suo lancio aspetta
spende sempre mi ammazzano e non sai che
lui che non era capace majlis con dove
la pallina
ma la bolina serve di portarlo credo che
ne troveremo un'altra donna posto c'era
un solo buco io l'ho preso in pieno
titolo e non me lo aspettavo mai
successo e non so se sono nato è corta a
questo qua e quelle tipo un casuale tipo
aver capito lo stesso e vieni qua e
arjen per questo fortunato
la prego che bravo ma io faccio ci
abbiamo fatto giusto giusto ma perché
dovrei siamo fermati dietro
togliti maledizione via mare per adesso
ce l'abbiamo fatta nonostante pietre ma
io sono la difficoltà aggiuntiva e lui
hard ma un giro su mamma mia che
coordinazione questo qua di piglio io
guarda poi l'anima rock e sono amico
controllare aiuto ai ragazzi mi lascio
nadai basta non superate la porta non
arrivò 6 ma per ora la tecnica va bene
allora non so bene cosa bisogna fare
tranne il credo che bisogna ok bravo non
è piccola comunque dobbiamo ha chiesto
una faccia che dio ma non ora ma se fa
così allora io faro io sto sopravviveva
ybarra para para gigi questo arrivo sono
fatti male ma la pallina
poi aspetta primo misero cielo ti volevo
riprovare slam dunk ragazzi vi prego
dove lo ritrovano troppo perché c'ero
pagare il momento il momento lo faccio
io
eccolo perfetto le scope strymer andiamo
su due ore però è stato è stata una
bella
l'esperimento questo ci fosse questa
roba è forse ci si deve attendere non ne
sono sicuro però vado io prima vista il
proprio pazzo vero ops sono troppi ma
sono morto c'è un problema di tempismo
ragazzi c'è una lega mazza da baseball
devo attaccare ti puoi attaccare volendo
la mazza da baseball ha chiamato
lavoravo ci provo salve sono vivo a
posto tutto ok amici e amici a
attenzione perché così è veramente utile
passati rare grazie raga mamma mia ma
che scalda così il nostro gioco rimane
ritirarti si userà un casino una casa
vabbè dai puoi stare fermo tu che già si
lontano non posso prenderti non ti posso
prendere mamma mia
l'ho preso se cui visse dai dai
stai fermo ma perché è questo qua
giocavo noi
ecco mattino di oggi ora ce l'ho fatta
abbiamo rotto il livello però ci hanno
fatto lo stesso e se non prendi un check
point avevo rotto se non me lo faccio
sempre non ci provo che devo fare
aspettava di vederci cibo soprattutto
quando beta forse se si può fare
aspetta aspetta aspetta
io d'alema c'è poi tre calcio alla paura
ma qua no se è finita se torno dice poi
mai avuti giu let's go my friends per la
gloria anche il mio metodo era molto
si no ragazzi ho un problema poi è bravo
stesso proprio così oddio è arrivato lo
stesso addio lasciati gravissimo d'amico
incredibile non ci riesco dai dai è
troppo velate prove più stimate fra i
live you go già un legno cogianco più ma
adesso da prendere impossibile rimasti
per tutto il giorno davanti se volete se
volete buttare giù io vado avanti dice
poi ti sto gioco cioè come funziona sta
roba che male una cosa soprattutto è per
famosi così molti aspetti è ma infatti
sono messo malissimo secondo me adesso
non ci arrivo più dovremo l'obiettivo è
il cappotto lui farlo vedere
no no 10 quanti se ne prendi la pratica
si fa serve solo un po di niente o no
ora non mi tolgo arrivare i vari emilio
triaca l'altro cosa vedo ma toglietevi
ecco ci aspetta si noti azzardato caro
ce la fa ce la fa non è vero forse ha sì
ce l'ha fatta
c'è l'uscita forse finito ragazzi ma no
sono svenuti pazza gigante c'è una mazza
gigante mi dissocio
io per me quello blu io vado a 100 e
sono palle adv entrarci dentro mentre i
ragazzi e sono partito non mi posso
fermare eccomi talenti ma se vi siete
detti
la riforma da minervino pronte a tenermi
non mi possa venire per fargli arrivare
prima
only one una sega
arriviamo mai a niente devo aspettarmi
per questo però niente perché ha
caricato livello ragazzi sto video è
stato bellissimo cioè mi piace un sacco
di fronte ci sono altre tre mappe nuove
lei faremo nei prossimi episodi quasi le
ragazze di 900 gli piace si chiede anche
al bacino
chiudiamo l'anno precedente il comando
ogni volta lo perda ecco qua beh ragazzi
[Musica]